what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to
cheesy telum featuring
dollar sign not directed by cole bennett
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know my goal is 20 000 subscribers this
month and each and every
one of you helps me get to that goal
okay
i hope this isn't like super fast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay they are lit they're getting it i
really like the tractor i think that's a
fun
added piece to them
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he keeps asking what are we
doing
and i think he's genuinely asking his
friend like what the plans are
we all have that friend that you know
you never know what you're doing and i
think that's why he's on the phone
talking to us
tell him what's up tell you what's up
tell him it's all every song tell him
what's up
tell him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] wait why did they just shoot
somebody what on earth
oh my goodness i thought they were
turning up in other shoes
in this life of mine i just want
[Music]
okay so they're saying he doesn't like
having friends that gossip right
valid point okay that's good he's
also talking about chasing the bad
getting money i think that's great good
bro i got the stick trying to blit
up and don't watch his body drop oh no
oh no pick him up and throw him watch
his body job i
i think they're talking about a murder
that is nice
stick sticks mix mix tips dip dip skips
whatever whatever
baby i'm getting in this setting
okay so he says i'm getting this cheddar
and
i think that's great because honestly
cheddar is a really great
version of cheese like i genuinely and
they're going to get a hair
guy
okay why are they saying god he made me
better but you're talking about dropping
bodies
it's just the count song is kind of
contradicting itself in my opinion but
it's just my humble opinion
[Music]
so they're saying turn me up um i don't
know what is the difference between turn
me up and turn up do they mean the same
thing
oh no well
i don't want to sit i don't want to say
it's your own fault for playing a game
in the middle of the road
but i have to say it that's your own
fault for playing a game in the middle
of the road what's
up what's up telling this song
tell him what's up
tell him what's up taylor what's up
telling this song
tell them what's up
oh dear are they just going to watch
them pick up the table
and go away okay that's the end um
this song is okay um out of
i'm actually gonna change my scale from
one to five
because i think that's a more accurate
scale in general
uh i would give this a three on a scale
of one to five not bad
not great um i probably wouldn't really
jam
out to it but like i thought the music
video was good
let me know in the comments if you agree
or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
and hit the notification bell that way
you're going to be notified for daily
videos i will talk to you guys next time